[Music]
fetish trap neither soul submitted by
Jessica from miss out.i misery miss our
necessary miss salwar salary miss salary
I'm sorry sorry miss Jackson and poor
ear with a man with a foot fetish admits
to preying on female Realtors know the
property porn oh yeah I have a wash on a
long time I forgot about that I don't
revisit those you just like dating it I
get to the best of both worlds where
you're just looking at the house and
you're watching my Realtors and males so
okay good
well he's a pretty sexy male kind of
cute too how do you made that joke
you said sexy okay so this takes place
in Phoenix and his name is Anthony and
I'm gonna show you a video of when this
news team approached him to call out
these pervs Valley Realtors call him the
foot fetish guy we tracked him well he's
a blows nose done Arizona's family how
come you keep contacting female Realtors
and saying you want to rub their feet
why do you face yeah what's up with us
his name is Anthony those female voters
through text and email offering to rub
their feet asking about their high heels
don't you think you're harassing these
women these female realtors I mean I
didn't it was meant yes so what I guess
I'm I apologize I'm sorry
I like Wow oh and he admitted to
injuries been going on for years right
Anthony couple yeah you give them foot
rubs before now he can't would you keep
trying yes
okay he's so weird I'm stupid but I'm
not doing it anymore
yeah right god stop yeah who's that lady
the Realtors
what's wrong with what he's doing this
is harassment he's asking them right now
so it's like he's baiting then he's
pretty much saying like acting like he's
interested in buying a home from them
and so he's wasting their time and then
that's when and finally like during the
conversation he'll start asking about
their feet heels or their feet she's
like hey I'm trying to sell a house not
[ __ ] sell my feet I know she's like a
prize or a pier [ __ ] not down
there literally isn't that part of the
service example if I go to like [ __ ]
Burger King or something right I'm like
hey can I get a cup of water like
technically they have to give it to me
but then if I just keep drinking water
over and over to like us sir you need to
buy a [ __ ] burger that's like well I
don't want a burger can I get a cup of
water and also let me see that [ __ ]
real quick for feet though yeah but for
sexual purposes yes he's getting off on
it yeah but she's already revealing the
feet we're in the [ __ ] open toe shoes
a hole so we're victim shaming now no no
buddy he's also asking you not I mean
like he's not being a perv and like
taking a secret pictures asking for it
is still a perv like if someone were
doing okay so if someone were to come up
to me and be like hey can I see your
tits yeah I would go back home no all
right it's on you gi good luck though by
the way huh you got a good rest of your
life it to infinity to deal with that so
question you can't you can't you can't
uh it's like violating me though but
he's asking the questions I say how are
you inappropriate question not for real
yes if someone's soul type I hate let me
see your dick tiger that is the question
but you better tell no right cuz you
can't you can't be Ken
you just want to piss everyone else
funny I know it feels like it this is
the basic understanding of what you have
to get this they are Realtors they are
wasting their time so that's the biggest
thing right so wait is little somebody
coming to barbell keep on ordering a
[ __ ] hamburger from you every day and
then they keep taking up your staff like
y'all but I want a hammer it weird Jim
listen bro Tim your hammer but we have
to do it though
you can kick out the customers you could
call the police you didn't mean we have
to do it why would barbell have to serve
hamburgers to this person to please the
customer that's what you're saying we
have to do right like one of our stuff
he's like [ __ ] this guy's coming again
so yes the open authorities just a
hammer guy [ __ ] yeah chase Berger today
but yes he's wasting her time but she's
also wasting his time giving these
stupid toys at these houses is the water
right but she doesn't know the tech
singing her job so she's sticking up to
her and that's like this let's say I'm
geo saw him alone in the [ __ ] like
cable guy comes you're not there and
then he's like oh so I fixed this by the
way can I suck your titties and [ __ ] and
in der it's only them two in the room
and it's like why well according to him
though all I have to say is no and the
guy's gonna walk away yeah no I'm gonna
say no well regardless if she says no or
not like it's just such a weird thing to
say to a stranger
like in the human interaction world I
see I see I get just so it feels like if
you asked any other question and the
real-estate realm do Tigers gonna get
raped I've been okay if you look like
how old is this rug how big is the
driveway like it's okay it's because can
I rub your [ __ ] toe asking about my
that's already weird okay check that's
outside of his scope of knowledge and my
house when I was listening to this story
I just thought wait there's something
one with questions and then I got
confused but I see like if it's outside
of the real estate question like how old
is your daughter yeah like that's like
what think about a thirsty guy that's
hitting on a girl right yeah and and
he's trying to get at her in all the
weirdest angles which would be like Oh
what's your favorite book but you
already know what his agenda is yeah so
you already like what the [ __ ] like this
[ __ ] like you already know what he's
trying to get but I also wouldn't
criminalize him like you just ask him
questions his game sucks he's asking
questions okay fine you are such a troll
I don't think he's trolling me he was
telling these Realtors that he's a
reflexologist and that's the reason why
he was so interested in their people you
got to be a five-foot Chinese ladies
your work is that why is he not he's a
bartender but yes he's in the wrong
field he should not do that that's
[ __ ] bad he might be really
passionate about it I don't know why
people like feet so much they're so
disgusting dude and recently I cracked
what am i doing there's some really good
looking feet but I know good looking
feet the nail to foot like toe ratio is
like good yeah I don't I don't see feet
and then [ __ ] you wanna just jizz all
over them and make smiley yeah cuz I saw
this foot fetish porn one time they were
like doing it and then he pulled out and
then she was like this and in Jack and
Jack him off like that he was like I was
like that does not look nothing but look
like it feels good pornos one of those
massage room pornos have Elsie knows yes
it's like I in the women's section or
whatever but then like the guide the
girl was doing that but it was like for
like a second I was like
okay that's kind of cool but it wasn't a
whole video or the focus of the video it
was just like a life sex that requires
work is not for me
damn Mario's a lucky girl so [ __ ]
lucky dude she gets to use me like a
standing dildo I just
he has quads of Steel yep right all
right let's go
you're just like a water baby yeah I try
to put no calories men oh she kills
electronic battles well the Sleep Number
she's moving with you yeah no she has to
be the horse yep she likes to work out
that's her thing you know what the moral
of the story is it's all about timing
and knowing your place because what's so
different between this and a guy that
meets someone cuz he was actually
looking for a house and then him and the
realtor connected and they started
talking and dating and he has a foot
fetish any ask sir can I rub that feet
and she goes oh please rub it see that's
very different from someone that just
comes in and he protests buy a house and
a connection a real and then he just
goes straight to the hey let me rub that
feet I feel all in the timing the long
order was almost thrown off about how
honest he was yeah cuz he kept trying to
make him stutter he goes no what's wrong
I'm stupid yeah I like it
are you gonna keep doing it yep you
could no no bad friend who's so honest
yeah face didn't match his demeanor I
was like oh this guy's a nasty little
[ __ ] and they started talking I
was like oh damn it Jess he also said
that he didn't realize he was creeping
women out he was like that's a question
he's like what he won't even hit on you
then and how did you fall into the trap
he didn't hit on me I did all the moves
rooms were already friends to she was
asking me the appropriate questions oh
you're asking him about his just saying
yes to all of them
I choose you already France oh she
rubbed his feet he was in the friends
we got out go in them hope he was not in
the friend zone why cuz you always been
[ __ ] Horning for me reported for this
she's got the horns for you I've been
warning been [ __ ] Horner for this
[ __ ] row mentally [ __ ] man right
here that's right mint chocolate chip
ice cream cake every year [ __ ]
three years I stopped it with two years
right three three years is pretty long
man hey but this year was a good one
what kick did you get her this time no I
got a concept that gets to one of her
favorite lines already getting all the
cakes and she nails it every time yeah
every year I will give him credit though
he does specify fruitcake yep see
do you like fruitcake direction I give a
credit action when we do the Huntington
Library thing getting you a new birthday
cake thank you cuz I try to get it for
you I am your actual birthday but they
didn't make it that day yeah thank you
or you know one bed
dad you got four Tycho's birthday it's
from the same bakery that one's good
it's a dulce de leche one that's [ __ ]
a [ __ ] bad dulce de leche cuz I think
Spanish I tried front cuz yo say
Dolce de leche you know what cake I like
the one you get for Casey every birthday
though that one is pecan but I watch it
that one is in rainbow that [ __ ] right
there though sent me to another universe
really yeah I try to get the [ __ ] did it
make it sex won't do that but dual sit
the alleged dulce de leche de leche so
chaser hey I like sex I just feel like
the move that means you like blow jobs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]